الله
اكبر ادى الف الفلسطينيين في شمال القطاع
صلاه الجمعه لاول مره منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
في ظل ظروف معيشيه صعبه سببها العدوان
المستمر على قطاع غزه اسال الله العلي
العظيم ان يرحم ضعفنا وان يجبر كسرنا وان
يتولى امرنا الله اكبر
رغم يعني قصف الاحتلال لمعظم مساجد قطاع
غزه الا ان الناس فطرت على حب الدين
الحنيف وفطرت على حب واظهار الانتماء
للدين الاسلامي هكذا هي الناس تقبل على
التمسك باداء الفرائض لله سبحانه وتعالى
رسالتنا الى الاحتلال ان شعب غزه وان شعب
فلسطين شعب مثاب شعب متماسك شعب يحب دين
الله سبحانه وتعالى وحب رسولنا الكريم فلا
يثنيه اي شيء عن مواصله الطريق العباده
والقرب من الله سبحانه وتعالى هذه المعاني
التي جسدت في الالاف الذين اموا صلاه
الجمعه اليوم في شمال قطاع غزه هي رساله
تحدي للاحتلال باننا سنرفع ذكر الله اكبر
ونعلي الاذان رغم رغم قصف المساجد
وتدميرها ورغم حرب التجويع والاباده
الجماعيه لمسر الاحتلال اذا هدموا المساجد
سنصلي في الشوارع اذا هدموا المساجد وبيط
الله تبارك وتعالى كم هدموا اكثر من 1000
مسجد سنصلي على ابواب بيوتنا سنصلي فيها
الشوارع حتى نل نلقى الله تبارك وتعالى
ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا وثبت اقدامنا
وانصرنا على القوم الكافرين لاول مره
يتمكن الاهالي هنا من اداء صلاه الجمعه
بعد تدمير الاحتلال جميع المساجد هنا في
شمال غزه انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه